map is used to run a function upon each
item in an iterable item like a list and
create a new list with the same number
of items but the values of each item can
be changed so here's an example we have
this list and then here's the function
and then we are going to map through
each item in the list and so here's the
function we're going to run we're going
to run this function on each item in the
list and now we're going to get a new
list so I can do print
result so then we can always just pass
it into the
list function
and then we can run the program again
two four six so one two three became two
for six so yeah whenever you want to do
run a function on each item in a list
you can use map